you mentioned Mexico you are from Mexico
what part of Mexico you from I'm from
Mexico City you're from Mexico City and
obviously Mexico and Mexican people were
brought up a lot during our election and
now Donald Trump has been elected I'm
curious how is does this as this
election affected you personally well
I'm just more and more proud of being
Mexican you know it's a and Anna's hate
is raising we we just have to be louder
you know it's the the contribution of
the the Mexican community here and the
Mexican American community here is huge
you know there's like the cultural
influence of Mexico here is is amazing
and it has made this country very rich
this diversity makes this country very
[Applause]
Andy brought up a really good point
we're living in a city that used to be
Mexico oh it's not at one point and and
you're right this is what you're saying
is that there's there's so much Lillis I
mean it's at times but at the same time
I think it's good because it's asking
for a reaction you know it's asking for
that other you know other side of this
country that is very proud to to and and
and that is ready to celebrate these
differences and to to talk about
diversity as the most positive thing of
this time you know this film does that
in a way with it's the most diverse cast
you've ever seen on a Star Wars film and
and and that's a good step it's a modern
approach to Star Wars and it's important
that we celebrate that diversity you
know yeah
[Applause]
you